president Trump suggests an unnamed
senior official in his own
administration is a traitor that
official published an anonymous article
in The New York Times claiming to be
part of a resistance inside the
administration the person claims to be
porting mr. Trump Trump's more misguided
impulses until he's out of office the
president demanded on Twitter
The Times must for national security
purposes turn him or her over to the
government
at once the paper defended the op-ed
saying it adds significant value to the
public's understanding of what is going
on inside the Trump administration major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning we asked the White
House what specific national security
standard justified the president's
demand for the identity of this op-ed we
got no reply for his part the Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo said he didn't
write it he was never really suspected
but speculation here and among former
officials has focused on a deeply
disgruntled member of the president's
diplomatic or national security team the
failing New York Times has an anonymous
editorial can you believe it anonymous
meaning gutless a gutless editorial
after spending the previous 24 hours
dismissing charges of a chaotic White
House found in Bob Woodward's new book
President Trump turned his attention to
denunciation from within in the form of
an anonymous op-ed in The New York Times
from a senior Trump official he's part
of the resistance within the
administration the up had said the
author and others are working diligently
from within to frustrate parts of his
agenda and his worst inclinations the
piece which drew withering White House
criticism goes on to say the root of the
problem is the president's immorality
mr. Trump's leadership style was
described as impetuous adversarial petty
and ineffective
moreover the author said his
impulsiveness results in half-baked
ill-informed and occasionally reckless
decisions that have to be walked back
they don't like Donald Trump and I don't
like them because they're very dishonest
people White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders called the author selfish and
said this coward should do the right
thing and
design the book means nothing it's a
work of fiction the fallout from
Woodward's book also continued in one
passage the president reportedly
describes his apology for not initially
denouncing neo-nazis after a deadly 2017
white supremacist rally the biggest
expletive mistake I've ever made I
didn't do anything wrong in the first
place
why look weak look back at Woodward's
past he had the same problem with other
presidents he likes to get publicity
sell some books but even the president's
most ardent defenders in Congress say
Woodward and his book should be taken
seriously and say there is a support
system and apparatus they called it
built around the President to withstand
his volatile and unpredictable ways John
major speaking of books your new one
will be called mr. Trump's wild ride
which seems an apt title on this morning
you in the reporting you did for that
book how much is that match up with what
you read in that op-ed in the New York
Times well on the idea that there are
those officials who consider things
they've stopped from happening as
important as accomplishments achieved by
this administration completely
consistent but John there is one thing
about that op-ed that I never found in
all of my interviews with senior
administration officials past and
present any conversation at all at any
level about invoking the 25th amendment
and using that dimension of the
Constitution to deal with an impaired
president incapable of doing his job I
never came across that in all of my
reporting and I am very skeptical about
that particular part of the op-ed hmm
all right major the 25th amendment
mentioned in that op-ed is a way to
remove the president from office all
that dissected which would take action
by the cabinet yeah right right yeah
thank you medium Thank You major